Olá meus amigos minhas amigas bem-vindos
a mais um vídeo aqui quem fala é Dr Alan
Machado Dutra é um prazer estar aqui com
vocês não deixem de ver até o final o
assunto de hoje são os alimentos pra
saúde hormonal da mulher Então nós vamos
falar dos alimentos top pra saúde
hormonal da mulher a partir dos 40 anos
de idade Então qual que é a importância
dos hormônios femininos é meio que Óbvio
isso mas vamos desenvolver esse tema os
hormônios são substâncias químicas são
mensageiros produzidas por glândulas
tecidos que são especializados então às
vezes até o músculo que não é uma
glândula pode funcionar como uma
glândula e também por neurônios Então
veja como os hormônios podem ser
produzido por vários tecidos diferentes
que não são chamados classicamente de
glândulas Então os hormônios são
fundamentais para equilibrar as funções
biológicas do corpo cerca de 50 tipos de
hormônios são produzidos pelas glândulas
endócrinas 50 hormônios pessoal sabemos
que nas mulheres o estrogênio a
progesterona e outros que são produzidos
pelos ovários trabalh em conjunto com o
hormônio luteinizante também conhecido
como LH e com o folículo estimulante o
FSH para regular os períodos menstruais
e conseguir a gravidez outros hormônios
regulam o libido metabolismo e funções
corporais adicionais então o equilíbrio
hormonal essa sinfonia dos hormônios
conversando entre si de maneira
equilibrada é essencial pra saúde
reprodutiva pra saúde emocional pra
saúde física então devemos evitar a todo
o custo desequilíbrios hormonais porque
os desequilíbrios hormonais podem levar
a doenças muito debilitantes como é o
caso do síndrome dos ovários
policísticos que são mulheres que têm aí
um desequilíbrio entre os os hormônios
androgênicos e os hormônios femininos
com intolerância à insulina também pode
levar menopausa que todas as mulheres
vão chegar nesse ponto em algum momento
e também infertilidade ou subfertilidade
ou até obesidade diabetes doenças
cardíacas e outros problemas de saúde
Então vamos falar de alimentos que podem
interferir com a sua saúde hormonal se
você apresenta enfrenta desafios com a
regulação hormonal pode ser benéfico
para você você pode se beneficiar de
alimentos que promovam um sistema
hormonal estável e equilibrado então
diversos alimentos podem auxiliar você
na Restauração desse equilíbrio hormonal
primeiro alimento que eu queria discutir
com vocês são as algas marinhas Por que
que elas são importantes elas são fontes
de ododo que essencial para equilibrar
os níveis de estrogênio e também
prevenir distúrbios de tireoide Ela é
Rica em zinco selênio e outros minerais
vitais paraa saúde hormonal e ela vai
ajudar também na saúde digestiva ou
saúde digestória por quê as fibras que
têm nas algas são muito interessantes
para regular os hormônios porque
facilitam a eliminação de excesso desses
hormônios e também de toxinas o segundo
alimento que eu queria discutir com
vocês é o abacate que é rico em gorduras
saudáveis e nutrientes que vão dar
suporte vão ajudar na produção hormonal
com vitaminas do complexo B com vitamina
E e com magnésio também vão ajudar no
equilíbrio da insulina e na saúde do
coração a saúde cardiovascular são
benefícios paraa regulação do açúcar no
sangue e manutenção da pressão arterial
que vai ficar mais equilibrada por conta
do potássio e magnésio presente no
abacate o terceiro alimento nos
castanhas as Nuts as oleaginosas são
ricas em vitamina E que vão reduzir
sintomas de menopausa como ondas de
calor palpitações insônia e também são
ricas em selênio que esse mineral é tão
importante para proteger a tireide
contra o estresse oxidativo vai ajudar
dando suporte à conversão dos hormônios
tiroidianos o quarto alimento a discutir
são peixes ricos em ômega-3 como é o
caso salmão e sardinha são importantes
esses ômega-3 especialmente o Epa o ao
ecosa pentenoico e o dha AOC cosa
hexenoico para a produção hormonal pra
redução da inflamação são
anti-inflamatórios eles beneficiam o
humor e ajudam na cognição então também
esses peixes que S grandes quantidades
de ômega-3 são fontes de proteína de
alta qualidade que é essencial para
obter aminoácidos que são
importantíssimos paraa produção de
hormônios o o quinto alimento são as
sementes de linhaça que vão promover o
equilíbrio estrogênico porque são fontes
de um tipo de fibra específica que é a
lignana que funciona como fitoestrógeno
que vai ajudar a equilibrar o estrogênio
que vai ser benéfico especialmente para
mulheres que têm excesso de andrógenos e
tem esse desequilíbrio também no
estrogênio tem mais estrogênio
proporcional do que progesterona e
também essas lignanas vão ajudar nas
mulheres que estão entrando na pausa e
também as lignanas melhoram a
fertilidade a melhoria dos parâmetros
metabólicos vai acontecer e um
equilíbrio hormonal que são promovidos
pela linhaça então um alimento muito bom
para promover uma melhor
fertilidade nas mulheres também vão
ajudar na saúde digestória na eliminação
de toxinas porque a fibra dietética
encontrado na linhaça vai ajudar a
promover saúde digestória facilitando a
eliminação regular ar e ajudando na
desintoxicação do corpo que é benéfico
para equilíbrio hormonal também vão
ajudar na redução da inflamação porque
tem propriedades antiinflamatórias os
ácidos gros ômega-3 presentes na linhaça
podem ajudar a reduzir os sintomas
relacionados a cinos de ovário
policístico e melhorar a saúde
cardiovascular o sexto alimento que nós
vamos discutir hoje é o brócolis o
brócolis é excelente porque tem
compostos de enxofre que vão promover o
detox do fígado esse composto de enxofre
vão dar suporte à eliminação de toxinas
e auxiliar no equilíbrio hormonal Então
as mulheres que TM ovário policístico
vão ter benefícios a usar o brócolis
porque ele vai melhorar a função
hepática vai ajudar na regulação dos
níveis hormonais vai contribuir para um
equilíbrio hormonal que é muito
necessário para lidar com condições como
acina dos ovários policísticos também
tem compostos bioativos é o caso do
sulforafano do endol tres cinol são
compostos que TM sido demonstrados em
estudos que T efeitos benéficos na
prevenção do câncer especialmente o
câncer de mama e no suporte ao detox
hormonal o sétimo elemento é o chá verde
maravilhoso chá verde rico em
antioxidantes que protegem contra danos
oxidativos dá suporte à saúde celular
vai ajudar na resistência à insulina vai
ajudar a aumentar a sensibilidade a
insulina melhorando a sensibilidade
insulina e combatendo a inflamação então
o chá verde por ter esse efeito
antiinflamatório e antioxidante vai
combater a inflamação sistêmica o que
pode ser particularmente útil para
mulheres que têm várias condições
inflamatórias incluindo endometriose e
síndrome dos ovários policísticos oitavo
alimento é um dos meus preferidos são os
ovos que vão promover equilíbrio
hormonal porque tem proteínas de alta
qualidade os ovos são verdadeiros os
polivitamínicos da natureza eles são
cruciais paraa produção e funcionamento
hormonal Porque vão fornecer aminoácidos
paraa construção de tecidos e síntese
hormonal também vão promover a saude
cerebral porque contém Colina que é
vital pro nosso desenvolvimento do
sistema nervoso central regulação de
humor e memória vão ajudar um
desenvolvimento fetal porque a colina
nos ovos é essencial pro desenvolvimento
neurológico do feto e vão ajudar também
no controle do apetite porque tem
bastante proteína e gordura saudável que
promove a saciedade Então os ovos são
excelentes para ajudar na saciedade
auxiliando no controle do apetite e na
perda de peso isso é muito útil pro
equilíbrio hormonal então o nono item
aqui na nossa lista são os alimentos
fermentados são muito importantes por
quê vão promover a saúde intestinal
alimentos como o iogurte caseiro
fermentado o missô o Temper o chucrute o
quinx são ricos em probióticos naquelas
bactérias do bem que vão ajudar na nossa
saúde são essenciais para uma digestão
eficiente paraa absorção de nutrientes
eliminação de toxinas e hormônios em
excesso Então os alimentos fermentados
vão promover o equilíbrio hormonal
combater a inflamação auxiliar na
regulação hormonal reduzir os riscos de
desordens hormonais então uma menor
inflamação está associado a um risco
reduzido desenvol movimento de desordens
desses tão importantes hormônios então
concluindo pessoal é muito importante
incorporar esses alimentos na sua dieta
e pode ser uma estratégia eficaz para
mulheres especialmente a partir dos 40
anos porque elas vão ter uma saúde
hormonal utilizando esses alimentos se
você associar a outros hábitos de vida
saudáveis como atividade física
meditação sono adequado então esses
alimentos oferecem uma variedade de
nutrientes essenciais que vão dar
suporte ao equilíbrio hormonal a saúde
reprodutiva emocional e física Muito
obrigado ter ido até o final desse vídeo
Você tá no meu coração você é
fera